you made your rap debut in 2021 and face
off can we get some more music from you
uh it might be coming down the line I'll
just tell you that I love how I every
time we see each other you go right for
it I do you go because you always come
and they say he's got to go so I got to
get right into it what are we looking
forward to seeing tonight on that stage
well we're looking forward to seeing
drive and power it's about drive it's
about power never mind
I'm looking forward to I mean the Ode to
hip-hop 50 years uh is incredible I got
my boy Buster right here so my favorite
freestyle of all time I think he it does
nobody compares to him
retired dudes with that freestyle that
Rhythm he has but also for me I'm here
with my beautiful wife Lauren and we
just wrapped as you know read one I've
been on that movie for four months so it
feels so good just to come here and just
uh give love to these incredible artists
and just watch and enjoy its music
how your mama is How's Mama thank you
she's doing really good I appreciate
that Jerry moment it was a scary moment
that was 3 A.M when I get that phone
call and you know we know when that
phone rings at 3am and it's a family
member it's not good so luckily she had
the wits about her to call she put the
paramedics on and I said hello this is I
said it's out to Johnson this is Dwayne
Johnson and paramedic said oh no I know
she's been telling us she's a Rock's mom
no listen sometimes you got to drop that
four letter word he drops it right away
I love it I love it so much okay I know
you got to go good to see you what are
we what are we wearing tonight sir Dolce
from Head to Toes okay
foreign